[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission est toujours consacrée
à l'actualité sportive dans le
département c'est parti pour le sommaire
football ont joué ce week-end dans le
championnat de 2e division de district
lyon pour s'est largement imposé contre
bilbao sur le score de 4 à 0
le résumé dans quelques instants
cyclisme quentin lafargue a réussi deux
bris en championnat d'europe aux
pays-bas le sportif licencié au vc
saint-quentin en yvelines a notamment
remporté l'or sur le kilomètre nous le
recevrons dans ce set 8 sport taekwondo
une compétition inter départementale
était organisé ce week-end à trappes le
rendez vous a réuni plus de 400
participants
autre particularité l'événement a permis
de former de jeunes arbitres nous y
reviendrons dans ce magazine l'actualité
sportive de la semaine c'est maintenant
sur tv 78
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres une
information golfique direction les
greens du golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines d'après le tour européen 24
1200 spectateurs sont venus assister à
la mundi open de france de golf du 17 au
20 octobre le décompte officiel est deux
fois moins important que pour l'édition
2019 il y aurait eu 6000 50 personnes
par jour en moyenne malgré la pluie et
la fraîcheur automnale de cette semaine
là c'est un demi échec pour cet open qui
a vu sa dotation divisés par trois cette
année suite au retrait du sponsor à
chinois à chênée ce qui a entraîné un
déplacement sportif du rendez vous
l'année prochaine l'événement pourrait
être organisé dans le sud près de khan
on continue à part du football en match
en retard du championnat de 2e division
de district guyancourt devait l'emporter
contre villepreux pour se relancer dans
la course à la montée
les aglyans courtois ont réussi à
s'imposer assez facilement 4 buts à 0
le résumé du match avantage de xavier
gens un derby blinois en match en retard
de des deux districts guyancourt recevez
villepreux une rencontre qui commence
fort après seulement deux minutes de jeu
d'aigus courtois marque par
l'intermédiaire de l'attaquant aurélien
lancé cueillis à froid les villes
provient encaissent un deuxième but
moins de cinq minutes plus tard par
l'inévitable aurélien lancé le match ne
s'arrange pas pour les visiteurs
troisième but sur ce centre 3 0 ce sera
le score à la mi temps on fait un très
très bon début de première mi temps
après ça on a un peu levé le pied je
pense qu'on met un troisième but aussi
qui nous a fait du bien
et alors les types dernière ils ont pas
mal poussé ville pourra pas mal poussé
mais on a été costaud défensivement
c'est une première mi temps idéal en
plus défensivement on a été très
constant n'a pas pris de but c'est plus
important compliqué mes joueurs ont fait
des cadeaux assez compliqué j'espère
qu'ils vont se réveillait déjà s'il se
réveille il joue mieux et ils montreront
que c'est pas une équipe qui prend des 3
0 à la mi temps
en deuxième période villepreux se
ressaisit poussent pour revenir dans le
match mais les joueurs de patrick
domingues sont maladroits dans le
dernier geste
ce sont finalement les gluants courtois
qui inspireront le dernier but de la
partie en contre
score final 4 à 0
maîtrisé le match du début à la fin on
mène 3-0 quand même au bout d'une demi
heure de jeu donc c'est quand même signe
d'une bonne maîtrise pourquoi je suis
satisfait du match qu'on a fait surtout
qu'on sortait de deux revers très durs
qu'on a pris deux fois 3-0
donc c'est important de se rassurer
défensivement et faire du bien au groupe
dans les têtes surtout au classement
guyancourt remontée se retrouve septième
de son côté villes pro est désormais
lanterne rouge de ce championnat avec un
seul nul depuis le début la saison
prochain match le dimanche 10 novembre
guyancourt recevra l'équipe 2 de trappes
évier preuve accueillera aux dents ont
continué à parler à football ont joué ce
week-end le 6e tour de la coupe de
france versailles dernier représentant
illinois dans la compétition a eu très
chaud face à viry châtillon les
versailles est classé une division au
dessus de leurs adversaires en nationale
3 sont allés s'imposer après une
stressante séance de tirs au but après
avoir concédé le match nul et vierge ils
l'emportent 5 à 4 résultat qui leur
suffit à se hisser au septième tour
comme la saison dernière
le rendez-vous sera programmée le 17
novembre prochain avec l'entrée des
clubs de ligue 2 shows on continue à
part du rugby en fédérale 2 plaisir à
réaliser une belle opération ce week-end
lors de la 6e journée les hommes de
sébastien roncalli se sont imposés sur
la pelouse de l'amicale sarcelles ce
dimanche le score 22 à 14 une victoire
qui permet au plaisir aux as de monter à
la 8e place avec un bilan de 2 victoires
1 nul et 3 défaites
on écoute l'entraîneur de l'équipe ce
résultat effectivement il était capital
pour essayer de se projeter vers ce
milieu de tableau à voir la
qualification
maintenant le prochain bloc va être
déterminant leur mais d'europe 1
dimanche marche arrêt et après on a
trois matches dont deux à domicile sur
des mêmes niveaux clés au classement
prochain match pour plaisir le 10
novembre prochain à domicile contre le
paris université club du rugby encore
avec le championnat de fédérale 3 lors
de la 6e journée versailles promis cette
année dans la division a réalisé une
très belle performance à domicile en
s'imposant sur son terrain contre eux ou
dans le derby i vinuales le score est
sans appel 46 à 17
un résultat qui fait leur bonheur les
verser entre dans le top 5 de leur poule
avec un bilan de 3 victoires 1 nul et 2
défaites
on regarde l'ambiance entre joueurs et
supporters juste après la rencontre
du basket à présent en nationale 3 3
équipes yvelinoise étaient sur les
parquets ce week-end des fêtes de
trappes d'un petit point 62 à 61 face à
saint thomas basket le havre le
chesnay-versailles basket s'impose 97 à
86 face à rouen
enfin à marly le roi était sur place et
sur le teint de montville 96 à 50
au classement le chesnay-versailles
toujours premiers trappe et 8e du
championnat
marly le roi à pointe à la dernière
place sur 12 ont joué également sur les
parquets de nationale 2 féminine le
chesnay-versailles promu cette saison
est tombé face à escaudain ce samedi
soir les i mean l'oise ont marqué 40
points dans cette partie en encaisser
soixante sa défaite la première de la
saison les fait reculer à la troisième
place du championnat prochain match
samedi prochain à domicile contre
franconville focus maintenant sur les
championnats d'europe se de piste la
compétition s'est déroulé mi octobre à
apeldoorn aux pays-bas les pistards
français qui s'entraîne quotidiennement
au vélotour national de saint quentin en
yvelines ont réussi à ramener à 8
médailles dans leurs valises dont 5 en
or mention spéciale à quentin lafargue
du lycée e sky qui remporte l'or sur le
km et le bronze en vitesse par équipes
et nous avons la chance de le recevoir
sur ce plateau bonsoir quand un hasard
vous n'êtes pas trop fatigué une petite
période de coupure après les prêts les
championnats du coup la reprise était
justement aujourd'hui même donc non ça
va bon sentez-vous ça ça va ça va ça va
la coupure a fait du bien et l'objectif
annoncé de repartir repartir au travail
pour préparer la suite de la saison
je le disais deux titres ça vous
convient c'était l'objectif
oui alors de deux titres moi j'ai réussi
à du coup à faire le titre aux
championnats du monde et un titre aux
championnats d'europe
récemment très honnêtement finalement
c'était pas
l'ambition première de la saison elle a
grandi tout au long de tout au long de
cette année mais mais je suis très
focalisée sur les disciplines qui seront
plutôt programme des jeux olympiques à
savoir la vitesse par équipes et aussi
le green à titre individuel mais voilà
je suis très très très content et très
heureux d'avoir fait d'avoir réussi à
faire ça sur l'épreuve du kilomètre une
épreuve qui me tient à coeur depuis que
je suis tout jeune donc je suis très
content d'avoir réussi à performer sur
ces championnats
justement vous lisiez le kilomètre
finalement c'est devenu votre votre
épreuve épreuve phare on peut dire de
titre cette année
oui championnats du monde et aux
championnats d'europe deux médailles
d'or auquel on peut du coup on rajouter
aussi les championnats de france qui ont
eu lieu à saint quentin en yvelines
courant août donc j'ai réussi à gagner
les trois gros championnat de l'année
sur cette épreuve là oui c'est une
discipline que moi j'affectionne
beaucoup depuis tout jeune et j'avais
déjà réussi à être championne d'europe
et championne chez les ch et des juniors
mais de là à réussir à faire ça chez les
élites c'était plus compliqué je suis
très heureux d'avoir d'avoir réussi
réussissent à cette année ses distances
qui vous plaît oui alors j'ai un profit
de 2 classes heures plus tôt plutôt
résistants et long je suis un poste 3
aussi en vitesse par équipes donc le
coureur qui fait le plus de distance de
l'équipe donc voilà je sais ça fait
partie de mes qualités et moi
j'affectionne cet effort et puis c'est
aussi une des épreuves dans laquelle
j'ai eu le plus de résultats donc
forcément quand on a des résultats même
si ça fait mal même si ça fait mal aux
jambes en continue de travailler pour ça
et il y a la vitesse par équipes 1 vous
disiez aussi médailles dont 11
ouais médaille de bronze plutôt
encourageantes avec avec la même équipe
qui était aligné au dernier championnat
du monde
à la différence de melvin landerneau qui
a intégré qui a intégré l'équipe en tant
que remplaçant et
au profil de michael d'almeida qui était
remplaçant chocolat du monde donc voilà
on était tous les quatre très performant
sur ces championnats championnat
d'europe et cette médaille de bronze
lance lance bien la saison l'important
c'est d'être performant
le jour j en championnat cette fois ci a
eu les hollandais les anglais qui ont
été plus forts que nous et qui ont été
très solides en terme de chronos il nous
reste beaucoup de travail mais mais on
est très motivé et on va se battre tout
au long de la saison pour justement à
baisser nos chronos vous étiez sur un
pic de forme ou pas sur ces championnats
d'europe
pas encore alors à titre personnel pas
forcément disons que la forme a été
optimisé pour justement être en capacité
de performer et de rivaliser avec
l'ensemble des nations européennes
l'objectif c'est quand même que que
cette forme s'améliore tout au long de
la saison pour avoir un premier vrai pic
de forme intéressant au championnat du
monde
et puis en espérant de bons résultats
aux championnats du monde qui nous
emmèneront jusque jusqu'aux jeux
derrière justement cette préparation
vous êtes licencié au vc e sky bc saint
quentin en yvelines
qu'est-ce qui vous apporte beaucoup de
choses et la chance de faire partie de
ce collectif depuis depuis l'année
dernière thierry série nous a tirés
fabre exactement nous à nous a
accueillis à bras ouverts l'année
dernière moi j'étais en relation directe
avec un des partenaires majoritaires du
club vous sert par l'intermédiaire de
laurent camin qui qui était mon
partenaire déjà depuis quelques quelques
années je leur ai proposé un projet de
développement sur plusieurs années avec
l'ambition de faire grandir le club sur
une discipline qui est la mienne la
piste on a la chance d'avoir recruté
grâce grâce au soutien du coup du
partenaire et de et de thierry fabre
quentin caleyron qui fait partie du club
depuis l'année dernière comme moi et de
nouvelles recrues toutes récentes qui
sont melvin landerneau et florian g bo2
deux autres athlètes de l'équipe de
france qui rejoigne du coup nos rangs et
un projet qui grandit au sein du club
exactement est ça fait partie d'une de
mes volontés qui ce qui est peut-être
personnel à la base mais qui devient qui
devient un vrai projet de club et projet
global puisque l'ensemble des athlètes
qui rejoignent mon projet sont
convaincus par parce que je peux leur
proposer ce que le club peut leur
proposer aujourd'hui donc je suis très
heureuse de pouvoir être être avec eux
être avec le vc sky team sert cette
année encore vos objectifs sur les
prochaines années y alliez il ya les jo
de tokyo et les jeux olympiques de tokyo
qui arriveront l'année prochaine
c'est forcément un objectif pour vous il
n'y aura pas le kilomètre il n'y a pas
le kilomètre le kilomètre fait pas
partie du pro fait plus partie du
programme olympique depuis déjà quelques
quelques olympiades malheureusement
malgré tout il ya d'autres disciplines à
savoir la vitesse par équipe sur
laquelle sur laquelle j'ambitionne
beaucoup de beaucoup de choses voilà moi
je je je pense beaucoup aux jeux
olympiques de tokyo c'est ce qu'ils vont
arriver le plus vite
ouais avant alors avant avant forcément
d'envisager à un vrai résultat sur les
jeux olympiques moi j'ai pour habitude
de rester focalisé sur les compétitions
qui viennent les unes après les autres
aujourd'hui avant avant de se focaliser
sur les jeux il va falloir être
performant en coupe du monde je serai à
hong kong début décembre puis à milton
au canada enfin mi janvier et ensuite il
faudra préparer les championnats du
monde y être performant conforter ma
place dans l'équipe de vitesse par
équipes pour pour espérer aller chercher
un résultat derrière aux jeux olympiques
surtout fin une sélection et un résultat
aux jeux olympiques donc beaucoup de
choses beaucoup de choses à faire encore
sur cette saison et et ce sera important
d'être performant à chacune des sorties
la question très rapidement léger ou
c'est un objectif de 7 ans et ça j'ai 28
ans 8 ans bientôt bientôt un non plus ce
système est oui alors ça fait partie des
choses auxquelles je des compétitions
auxquelles je pense je suis dans un
premier temps focaliser sur sur tokyo
mais je compte pas du tout arrêté à
l'issue des jeux de tokyo donc on y
pensera après je vous garde quelques
instants avec nous pour parler des jo de
2024 justement le logo officiel a été
dévoilée la semaine dernière dans un
rond doré symbolisant une médaille dont
on voit une flamme olympique celle ci
laisse apparaître un visage stylisé
représentant marienne l'allégorie de la
république française comme vous pouvez
le voir sur ces images les créateurs
veulent donner une identité à
l'événement et apporter une touche
révolutionnaire le montant total investi
pour ce logo n'a pas été révélé je
rappelle que ce logo sera arboré à dans
les yvelines le département va
accueillir le vtt et le bmx le cyclisme
sur piste l'équitation le pentathlon
moderne et le golf sur son territoire
votre avis sur ce logo difficile eddy
ferhi bois pour moi j'ai pas de jets pas
forcément d'avis très déterminés sur ce
sursaut logo là après j'ai compris que
c'était la première fois que le même
logo été utilisée pour les jeux
olympiques pour les jeux paralympiques
et pour le coup j'estime que ce cette
décision est une bonne décision qu'à
titre personnel le logo i
il me convient me convient très bien le
rapport à la médaille dorée est un bon
symbole on espère en tout cas que vous
l'aurez cette médaille d'or aux jeux
olympiques de 2024 ans continuera
évidemment vous suivre sur vos
prochaines compétitions
on va maintenant parler de la transat
jacques vabre louis burton le ski par
embolie tendent de 34 ans participe en
ce moment même à la célèbre course
il est parti ce dimanche du port du
havre avec son coéquipier davy beaudart
sur cette course au large qui relie la
france au brésil sur ce dernier pointage
il était 11e au classement des imoca sur
son bureau vallée son objectif le podium
est encore envisageable son bateau
devrait arriver à la mi novembre
on continue à parler de louis burton le
skipper de rambouillet s'est prêtée à
notre désormais traditionnel jeu des
trois questions regardez la séquence
[Musique]
à
j'ai commencé la voile parce que j'ai eu
la chance de
grandir dans la forêt de rambouillet et
d'avoir
papa qui aimait beaucoup le bateau et
les parents qui aimait aller en bretagne
et je crois que la première fois c'était
pour se débarrasser de nous dans mon
frère et moi le matin entre 8h et midi
pendant les grandes vacances
[Musique]
mon meilleur souvenir sur l'eau
probablement l'arrivée de ma première
route du rhum en 2010 qui était
isation de mal c'est vrai que quand on
habite et qui ont grandi en région
parisienne et dès qu'on est passionné de
voile on peut rêver de faire tous ces
trucs là toutes ses courses au large et
mené cette carrière là mais c'est pas du
tout évident d'y arriver donc
donc voilà c'est le graal de faire une
route du rhum donc quand on boucle sa
première route du rhum c'est c'est
quelque chose d'exceptionnel c'est
réaliser un rêve quoi
cette année c'est de terminer la transat
jacques vabre dans les cinq six
possibles et se préparer pour le tour du
monde l'année prochaine ce sera ma
troisième participation consécutive
c'est la course la plus dure en course
au large et le terminer ce sera déjà
bien et en général quand on termine le
vendée globe avec un bon bateau de toute
façon on a un bon classement et
monde est content retour sur la terre
ferme en prend maintenant la direction
de trappes samedi et dimanche une
compétition interdépartemental entre les
hauts-de-seine paris les imint est
organisé au gymnase broustal l'eau
rendez vous était destiné aux catégories
cadets minimes juniors et seniors au
total près de 400 sportifs dont 84 ap se
sont inscrits sur cette première
compétition de l'année dans le
département on écoute l'un des
organisateurs benoît accordant au micro
de tv 78 pour la coupe qui est organisée
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
qualification à la clé simplement c'est
la découverte de des combats pour
certains jeunes pour qui c'est la
première fois qu'ils sont confrontés à
une vraie opposition sur un terrain et
puis pour les autres passes et continuer
à travailler les techniques travailler
un peu avec les enseignants au club
comme ça c'est pour aujourd'hui hier
c'était une compétition qualificative
pour les championnats régionaux
pendant cette compétition
interdépartemental on pouvait voir de
nombreux jeunes présents dans autour des
tapis pour arbitrer notamment inès une
jeune sportif du club de trappes à
montage de romain respini l'arbitrage
une passion pour inès tarawih la jeunes
taekwondoïstes de 15 ans licencié au
club de trappes a décidé d'endosser ce
costume en 2016 aujourd'hui la sportive
arbitres sur une compétition
interdépartemental j'aime bien arbitré
quart
habitué
ça donne du poids
une certaine indépendance sur moi
du coup je me suis combats tant que tous
les faits d'arbitré ça permet du coup
d'avoir double casquette et je trouve ça
du prince est intéressante
pour s'améliorer inès reçoit
régulièrement des conseils d'arbitré
plus expérimentés présents autour des
combats pendant les compétitions
une phase actuelle un peu trop
c'est bien s'est bien déplacé pas bien
vu des choses est ce que j'apprécie
énormément chez elle c'est son sérieux
sa présence elle écoute les conseils je
les applique sa qualité première c'est
très clairement son impartialité
même si elle doit arbitrer quelqu'un de
son club je sais que elle fera aucune
différence entre les combattantes
l'arbitrage un axe fort pour le
développement de la discipline
aujourd'hui comme inès une vingtaine de
jeunes sont présents pour arbitrer la
compétition c'est extrêmement important
pour notre sport d'avoir des jeunes qui
s'impliquent dans l'arbitrage
et c'est aussi important pour eux parce
qu'en tant que combattant de connaître
les règles et les ficelles d'arbitrage
c'est ce qui va leur permettre
d'améliorer encore leurs capacités dans
les combats il n'essaie sperme
maintenons passer son diplôme jeune
arbitre national et pourquoi pas rêver
encore plus grand et devenir arbitre
international ce week-end s'est déroulé
le championnat de france des majorettes
au gymnase gérard philipe de saint cyr
l'école des clubs des quatre coins de la
france ont participé à cette compétition
sur deux jours pour nous éclairer manon
varaldo est avec nous sur ce plateau
qu'on soit bon soir vous étaient sur
place une compétition qui a débuté
samedi dès 6h30 du matin le championnat
de france des majorettes organisé par
l'amicale fanfares et majorettes de
france s'est déroulé pendant tout le
week-end il a regroupé 209 participants
venus de toute la france pour présenter
leurs solos pas en 2 minutes 30 pour les
plus petites
deux minutes pour la toute petite 6 ans
et 3 minutes 30 pour les grandes
on essaye de prendre des thèmes
différents alors il y en avait pour tous
les goûts j'ai pu voir le soldat rose la
jardinière la pluie l'arbre d'automne ou
encore jasmin jasmin interprété par
vania huit ans majorettes à saint cyr
l'école depuis deux ans elle fait partie
des 19 ce lot présenté par le club qui
compte 56 adhérents
acer annonce
et je suis très contente de faire un
championnat c'est pour la première fois
que je fais ça juste avant le passage
les majorettes répète je me suis rendu
dans leur salle d'entraînement les arts
voit sa chorégraphie avec sa coach cathy
extrait je me plie pas la tête plus
grand plus grands
c'est joli c'est avec le doigt
attention parce que c'est l'intérêt que
tu voles c'est beaucoup de répétitions
pour ces jeunes filles des chorégraphies
préparées depuis le mois de juillet par
leur coach on essaie de trouver des
thèmes originaux pour pouvoir pour voir
les petites en fonction de leur
personnalité
léa 8 ans est passé devant les jurés
elle a présenté sa composition c'est une
jardinière qui entretient son jardin
avec sa petite maison vania alias jasmin
a elle aussi présenté sa chorégraphie
avec sa lampe devant quatre juges plus
de précisions sur leur notation
il ya plusieurs catégories la
chorégraphie la présentation le bâton la
technique de bâton alors il faut que les
mouvements soient faits dans le bon sens
et surtout bien tenir le bâton mais
également faites attention à vos pieds
écoutez justin juste après son passage
j'étais un peu stressé au début j'ai
vraiment oublié mes pointes de pieds
mais quand je finis je me suis rendu
compte que c'était vraiment bien et j'ai
très envie de recommencer
elle laisse ansérienne était à domicile
mais des clubs venus de toute la france
ont fait le déplacement pour ce
championnat
parmi les majorettes des majors quand
j'ai questionné et lucas 10 ans du club
de wattignies dans le nord de la france
sur sa pratique
voici sa réponse j'aime bien en faire
vous l'avez vu c'est comme une évidence
pour lui la présenter et son solo en
incarnant elvis presley les majorettes
et majors n'ont pas échappé aux
traditionnelles photos de leurs proches
le public a beaucoup encouragé les
participants l'esprit était familiale
énormément stressé c'est beaucoup
d'émotion de voir
de voir toutes ces petites passes et
encore plus essentielle à notre un peu
la larme à l'oeil que possible pour
réussir dans ce sport malin alors pour
être une bonne majorettes il faut être
assidu aimer la danse et surtout aimer
les paillettes des paillettes évidemment
4 maintenant sur montigny le bretonneux
la ville accueillait ce week-end un
rendez-vous d'échec le 18e tournoi
d'automne organisé par la dame noire le
club local de la ville le principe des
groupes de dix participants se sont
affrontés pendant l'événement quelles
sont les recettes pour remporter la
victoire aux échecs
l'un des organisateurs jean marie pour
alain répond au micro de manon varaldo
ce qu'il faut il faut de la
concentration et bien s'entraîner
régulièrement parce que ça paraît pas
mais c'est quand même physiquement
éprouvante
même si on est assis transpire d'une
héroïne quand même
on passe maintenant notre page agenda
[Musique]
les invités entrent en plateau on les
aura dans quelques instants commence cet
agenda par un rendez vous insolite pour
la troisième année consécutive la ville
des clayes-sous-bois va accueillir un
trait laurine le concept des courses
sont organisées ce vendredi 1er novembre
à partir de 9 heures et les participants
doivent courir déguisée au programme à
19 km 10 km et un 10 km marche nordique
le départ sera donné depuis le parc jean
car ayant des clés sous voir on continue
cet agenda par une course la course
royal justement organisée par la commune
de fontenay le fleury cette course
pédestre réunira encore cette année
plusieurs centaines de participants elle
sera programmée à ce dimanche pour nous
parler de son rendez vous nous recevons
sur ce plateau vous les avez aperçu
juste avant philippe gronier adjoint au
maire nous recevons également des
associations benoît averine le président
de l'association franchissant le mur une
association qui pratiquent les courses
en joëlette et vous êtes présents sur le
rendez-vous depuis à trois ans également
avec nous pascal gallois président ile
de france 2 d'une espoir qu'ils se
rassurent la course pour les jo elle est
également alors est-ce que vous êtes
prêts à quelques jours de l'événement
tout à fait toute la course est prête il
manque les derniers petits arrangements
mais tout tout se passe bien nous sommes
à aujourd'hui à plus de 550 participants
qui était déjà une belle petite victoire
pour moi qui ne pensaient pas parce que
c'est vrai que pendant les vacances
c'est pas toujours une commande et c'est
pas toujours évident de faire venir les
gens sur la course mais voilà que vous
disiez tout à l'heure c'est vrai que
c'est un parcours qui est exceptionnelle
puisqu'on parle de la pièce d'eau des
suisses de versailles et on traverse la
plaine de versailles le parc du château
de versailles pour arriver dans la
commune de fontaines fleuries
quel sera le parcours c'est vraiment un
parcours compliqué ou pas l'ia des
petites complications mais c'est
beaucoup plus de plat et avec ce qu on
dit dans le jargon découvrir un petit
casse pattes comment à la fin de course
pour leur faire voir que voilà c'est
n'essayez pas non plus une partie de
plaisir
du coup présents sur cet événement
également au niveau des dunes d'espoir
pourquoi oui donc depuis plusieurs
années nous sommes présents parce que
j'adore cette course au changement du
micro that un peu loin j'adore cette
course en tant que coureur le parcours
est magnifique l'ambiance est conviviale
et les jeunes à mobilité réduite adore
également la course et grâce au gel est
poussé tiré par quelques cours aux
bénévoles ils peuvent participer et
c'est un grand plaisir
ce sont des grands moments de partage
d'émotions d'énergie de de joie est
vraiment cette course est magnifique et
tous les jeunes qui peuvent y participer
en juillet grâce à mon association grâce
à l'association de benoît sont très
heureux de participer et si certains
coureurs nous croiser veulent nous aider
à pousser et tirer les geôles est qu'ils
n'hésitent pas qui est qu'il poussait
tiers avec nous les joëlettes et ils
seront les bienvenus
pascal gallois même si c'est moi c'est
moi même par non excusez moi pareil
franchissant le mur est ravi de
participer à cette course c'est c'est
une course qui comprend les qui comprend
l'esprit des joëlettes c'est à dire que
souvent quand on s'inscrit
les organisateurs nous disent ok mais
vous vous mettez à l'arrière là les
organisateurs nous disent non devant on
a compris l'esprit c'est un partage les
personnes en situation de handicap sont
devant peuvent faire profiter à tout le
monde du fait de participer à cette
course donc c'est extraordinaire pour
nous comme le coureur cette année
j'espérais atteindre la barre des 1000
mais ça va être un peu difficile mais si
on devrait arriver dans les 700 750
participants et une petite un petit plus
si je voulais mettre cette année sur la
course royal 1 euro par participant sera
reversée au téléthon qui aura lieu à
fontenay le fleury de 7 décembre
combien de mois de préparation pour ce
type d'événement on attaque à peu près
la préparation à partir du mois de mars
de l'année d'avant un homme a oui à peu
près un an avant au niveau de
l'association même chose tout où tous
les week-ends en fait en ile de france
donc voilà donc nous sommes entraînés et
les jeunes sont très heureux de
participer et très heureux également
participé à cette superbe course
est ce que c'est une course qui grandit
d'année en année nous avons fourni ces
c'est la septième édition nous avons
commencé alors moi c'est la sixième
édition que je prends en août nous
avions entre 250 et 300 participants
nous pouvons aujourd'hui qu'on à 750
participants
c'est quand même une course qui commence
à avoir de l'alluré et qui vient
également les participants viennent de
province également que ce soit voilà il
n'est pas qu'en région parisienne
j'ai un petit groupe de 35 personnes qui
viennent de rouen spécialement pour
cette course sauf qu'ils ont appris il
ya de plus en plus de jeunes
de plus en plus il ya la barre combien
trois cette année trois cette année si
ça fait alors dernière question très
rapidement en 10 secondes qu'est ce
qu'on peut vous souhaiter cette année le
beau temps déjà pas trop de pluie pour
les participants et puis un succès tout
ce que tout ce que tu veux savoir et
puis normalement l'année prochaine les
prochaines merci à tous les collègues
passé sur ce plateau
merci beaucoup la course royal ce sera à
ce dimanche 3 novembre
à bientôt sur tv 78 c'est déjà la fin de
cette émission
[Musique]